everybody and welcome back to politics
today it's time for a Hickory Hill and
the description of the scenario States
then originally it's a nature preserve
and the park must us abide by local laws
preventing structures to be built above
tree heights and that's the catch for
this scenario that's going to make this
one a little bit more difficult use the
hilly terrain to your advantage by
building close to the ground is what
they suggests or actually that's what I
suggest anyway
it's weird to read this as the person
who actually described this in the first
place anyway the scenario states that we
must get an experiences rating of 80%
and an overall Park rating of 85 percent
so neither of these are going to be too
difficult but then the whole terrain
thing is definitely an extra challenge
on top of that not to mention that I
think this park is a little bit broken
when you start out with it as well but
that's something which we'll see right
now it's kind of a map that even though
it looks nice it's not as functional as
it would like you to believe I think and
even then I think you can tell quite
quickly if you've played a few scenarios
in Park Tech's that this map is not that
great from a management perspective at
least so we have quite a large park and
everything is very spaced outs
I guess the main attraction here is the
large wooden roller coaster which is
kind of the example of how you can use
the terrain and to actually get a big
roller coaster in even though you can't
build above tree height although I also
have to say tree height is quite liberal
in here you can definitely build above
the height of the trees which are here
just because the trees in pike tanks are
a bit scaled down and stylized
but yeah you're quite limited in terms
of how its whole you can build but aside
from this wooden roller coaster there
are some things which are very spread
out so there's a lot of paths which is
very useless there's just a spiral slide
here and then around the other side of
Park there's a carousel and then there
is a train ride which nobody seems to be
riding one guest okay one guest is on
the train so that that isn't great and
then there's a bunch of path elements
which seem to be vandalized
so that's something to tackle as well
and the depot is all the way over here
and employees have to walk so far to
even get to the staff room or to get
supplies here I'm not sure if there is
assist yeah there is a system to at
least bring supplies somewhere else in
the park so that's the essence but the
shop over there isn't even linked up so
yeah we have a bunch of stuff to fix
here but hopefully there's also some
useful stuff in the right section I
don't even remember exactly what you
start off with okay so we have an
enterprise and the rights that the park
already gives you not too great this
could actually be a good park for an
Alpine Coaster I haven't tried to build
one yet I know they're not very
profitable coasters but they are also
really cheap and I would love to try to
build one just because I haven't tried
to build one yet and a bobsled coaster
which I think works well with this
terrain as well and a spinning coaster
which usually aren't too tall anyway so
that's doable I think actually the
coaster types are decent I'm just gonna
have to research flat rides a bit more
and that aside I mean I'm not concerned
about the water rides we can always get
a log flume in but there are already
paddle boats so that's fine I think
right
so having surveyed the damages I think
this park is definitely salvageable and
I think I'm just gonna start building
some rides and filling in all of this
empty space that's right and make it
happen
so yeah let's get started alright
scratch that intro something happened
which hasn't happened in this series
before and which I didn't really know
how it's a handle so I just ended up
cutting a bunch of footage and
commentary that I made because I didn't
really like where the park was going and
I figured that well rather than putting
out an episode now I wasn't a big fan of
I should just start all over again and
do things a little bit better this time
both aesthetically and from a gameplay
perspective so that's generally what I'm
doing I'll throw in maybe a picture of
what I created first somewhere actually
no just right here right now so yeah
that didn't make the cuts but I decided
to do something
and eventually I liked it enough to keep
going and that's what you're looking at
at the moment sorry for that whole
confusing sort of situation what I
actually want to do is build an alpine
village kind of thing here very much
inspired by Austrian and German and
Swiss villages and there'll be a few
different architectural styles here but
something that I'm starting off with is
the church at the village because that's
sort of the main iconic architectural
elements in a lot of these kinds of
places and specifically these churches
like to have lots of classical Baroque
kind of details so that's something that
I'm trying to go for here as well as the
typical traditional onion domes and very
decorative spires
so it's gonna be very difficult to build
a proper onion dome in this game but as
far as the Baroque details and sort of
overall shape of the building goes I
think you can get pretty close in Prague
texts so what I decided to do is create
this sort of stepped-up roof with all
kinds of well vaulted arches I assume
inside and then these flying buttresses
on the outside just made out of simple
wooden pillars and cornice pieces but I
think it generally sells the look quite
well and then on the top of the two
towers in front we have these sort of
onion dome like structures which don't
really work out that well but given the
roof pieces in vanilla parka texts I
think they worked decently so I was
pretty happy with the overall look of
this building and in the end I decided
to put a carousel inside of it and
remember this because eventually I kept
playing and I forgot that there was a
carousel inside this building so I built
another carousel right in front of it
and I still haven't fixed that maybe I'm
just gonna keep it that way I don't
really have any other rides to put in
here the right selection that you get
from research is pretty limited so yeah
it's just a bit of a funky mistake that
I ended up making before I move on I
have to admit that this building was
largely inspired by the church in Sankyo
Han
Tirol in Austria which is very similar
in terms of the color scheme and shape
and basically everything and I just
wanted to use this as a reference
because in parka text it can be very
difficult to figure out what you can and
cannot do
so sometimes trying to get as close as
possible to a real life building sort of
results in something very different that
still feels quite nice and that's what I
ended up doing with this building I
think because even though I used the
real life church as an example in pretty
much everything that I did the building
and Parks I did turn out looking quite
different just by nature of how
different the pieces are now for my
second building building a small corner
building here mostly as an experiment to
see how well the wooden pieces would
work for some detailed timber work
especially on the corner there where I
have a small little I don't know what
you would call it I guess it's a small
Tower that juts out and has some bay
windows and it's a little bit off-grid
and it's hard to get the shape of it
just right but I think with the base the
basic pieces so the basic cylinder to
create the shape of the tower itself and
then two of the cylindrical triangle
pieces cones there you go on top of it
it creates a sort of steep spire spires
are always a bit difficult in parka
tectum nail because there are very few
pieces that you can actually use for
them but usually if you just mix
especially the basic shape pieces
together in certain ways you can sort of
create the overall feeling of a steeper
spire and moving on to the third
building just a very very simple wooden
building in the style of typical Alpine
mountain houses I had to keep it on grid
because I wanted it to connect to the
corner building also because it serves
as the entrance of the queue line for
the wooden coaster right there but next
to it I wanted to place a building which
I wanted to be slightly detached and I
wanted to try and experiment and see if
I could make one of these overhanging
roof
that typical Alpine buildings always
have so while the roof is on a full grid
the rest of the building will all be on
a half grid which is always slightly
annoying because it means that you
cannot use any of the cornice or corner
pieces so I ended up having to use very
tiny little cubes to make the horizontal
wooden beams here but thankfully I can
at least fill in the rest with vertical
pillars so that wasn't too difficult but
it does mean that I can't go to in
detail with the detailing of this
building because a lot of detail pieces
do have to conform to four grids and
this sometimes makes it a bit difficult
to create overhanging roofs
and I think actually overhanging roofs
are one of the main struggles in vanilla
architects there are some mods where you
can place pieces off grid and also some
mods that just give you off grid roof
pieces but in vanilla I think one of the
trickiest things to get right about
buildings is the the overhanging roof
aspects and usually I like to stay on
grid and just add overhanging roofs here
and there as a bit of flavor but it can
also work to create a roof that is fully
on grid and just make the building walls
and other pieces themselves on a half
grid in between four grids like that and
as a final part of this big row of
facades I ended up adding a very small
little facade on the side there none of
that stuff is actually functional it's
mostly just decoration really the only
thing in that whole row is the actual
entrance to the wooden coaster so yeah
but I think it is pretty noteworthy that
for the corner building I also use the
sort of half grid trick so while the
most of the building itself is on a full
grid the ground floor is on the half
grid sort of creating this setback that
makes for a small gallery that
theoretically people could walk through
but in reality of course there aren't
any paths but it does look pretty cool I
think to have this building overhang
slightly above its foundation and that's
also something that typically a lot of
medieval buildings do as well now moving
on from that I figured it was time to
add a food courts to this
and you might say there's already its
hiney food courts in the corner which is
totally true there is a small food court
with a separate zone for employees also
but that one I'm not a really big fan of
I really wanted to have something more
central and I wanted something to
interact with the lake in a bit so this
is what I ended up adding just this
large roof with a small food court
underneath it and these overhanging
sections so that people could also sit
down underneath the roof and I don't
just have to count on umbrellas or
parasols to keep people the sheltered so
yeah it's almost like a bit of a
lakeside house or mansion or something
like this
or like a Fisher Pier house or whatever
that was my general sort of intent with
this it was actually a bit inspired by
catfish Cove by shyguy which is one part
of shy guys I'm not exactly sure the
park is called anymore it might be
wonder world but I'm not 100% sure but
anyway it was an rct3 park and a
real-life miniature model as well which
a lot of custom scenery sets in the
early days of r63 were based on most
famously I think alpine village which
still kind of serves as inspiration for
me in park attacked for alpine buildings
to this day but another one is catfish
Cove right next to alpine village which
has a lot of sort of wooden buildings
which play with the water and swampy
sort of natural environments and for me
that was a small inspiration for this
food courts building as well and then on
the back I'm not sure why I figured it
would be a good addition to at that
little house at the back but I just kind
of like the way that it looks it doesn't
actually solve any logistical problems
or anything it's really just decoration
there for some reason I just didn't feel
like a big tent like roof structure
completely on its own would fit very
well into the layout of the park now
next to that is the merry-go-round that
I just built which was kind of
unnecessary I just totally forgotten
that there was a merry-go-round in sight
nature
because to be fair that's a very weird
thing to do not gonna lie but at the
time I just thought it would be a good
idea to at least turn that turn the
church into something useful
but yeah next to that I'm adding another
building which kind of uses a trick to
have overhanging roofs so I'm using a
very shallow roof to create a ground
floor which is an overhanging section
almost like a Western kind of building
it's not something that you would
typically see in Alpine architecture but
I just figured it would fit in very well
here especially considering the fact
that I wanted to build a pavilion over
the merry-go-round as well as I'm doing
right now and as always I'm trying to
come up with new ways to create
pavilions for flat rides and in this one
I ended up creating this structure with
different roofs on different levels and
also just using different roof pieces
and actually I'm really happy with it
it's one of my favorite covers that I've
made for a flat ride so far for some
reason I feel the the white and orange
color combinations also work quite well
with the dark wood ruining the dark roof
what am I saying the dark wooden pillar
pieces that I'm using and that also kind
of come from all of the surrounding
buildings
so yeah I'm pretty happy with that cover
and then coming back to the building
next to it I'm just adding a green roof
because I didn't have a lot of Queen
roofs yet and as always as for a lot of
the buildings in this park some timber
work just to make it fit in a bit more
and some simple dormers and other
details to finish the look and honestly
all of this is quite simple and I'm
trying to avoid as much as possible sort
of falling into certain habits of
playing this game which after a while of
playing it and doing all these scenarios
I'm really kind of anxious of developing
a set building style and just falling
back into this time and time again so at
least when it comes to detailing and
things like this I'm trying to do
something slightly different every time
but especially with some of these
smaller buildings it's really difficult
to keep doing different things sometimes
your options are just really limited and
all you really need to do is plop down a
wall with some simple pillars and
roofs I just kind of feel bad anytime
that I sort of recycle building ideas
like that hence why honestly personally
I'm really happy with the cover for the
merry-go-round because it's really
unlike anything I've done so far as well
as the church building which is pretty
unique as far as my parka tech buildings
are concerned as well and here for no
other reason than I just felt like it's
I ended up building a big steel
structure for the bridge which is a bit
over the top
because it doesn't really need it
technically it's just covering a small
gap in the past so it doesn't really
need to cover a large distance there's
no valley or river or anything like that
I just figured it would look nice and it
would finish the the sort of main plaza
of the park on this side quite well so
ended up putting this whole big
structure here I don't know sometimes I
I think I probably have to feel a little
bit less bad about dropping the pretense
of making everything realistic and
functional and just do stuff because it
looks nice because it's it's often its
own good fun anyway but here I think you
can really see the the setup of this
this Park layouts developing I have the
main plaza right in front of the church
with their own typical path textures and
even some brick sidewalks and from there
on it develops into these more natural
stone textures and smaller paths going
into different directions and actually
go into the rides themselves so it's
almost a very Disney like approach of
creating a Main Street
it just doesn't follow the same typical
layouts of a Disney park because I have
to work with the with the terrain that
we get here or really that I made for
myself here I suppose I kind of
underestimated one of the difficulties
about this scenario and that's something
that I will get to right now because it
is time to build a rollercoaster and a
very significant challenge in this park
is that you're not allowed to build
above tree Heights now a tree height
here is pretty liberal because as you
might be able to tell the trees in
parsecs are mostly tiny but you're about
allowed to build up to the height of a
bubbly tree I think so yeah you can
definitely go above the height of the
trees they're already there but you
really have to stay close to the ground
at all times if you want to build a
coaster
so the coaster than that I decided to
build was a spinning coaster because on
my initial try of this scenario I built
an Alpine Coaster and my first ride and
that thing didn't make any money
whatsoever so this time I'm gonna try to
actually make this scenario successful
and not fail it's so I'm going with my
best bets and that is the spinning
coaster which I think it's just best at
bringing in guests and getting me good
profits so here we go
a spinning coaster it is I think it also
works really well with the hillside here
because all you really have to do is
stick to the hillside with a small lift
hill and then just do a bunch of twists
and turns with some mid-course brake
runs in between lining down that hill
and ideally I was thinking finally
coming down to the lake and swooping
over the lake in one final turn before
going back into the break run to go to
the station and this is eventually what
I ended up doing and I'm pretty happy
with this layout it's one of these
layouts that is just super simple just a
bunch of turns and hills nothing much to
it but given the terrain of the scenario
and the fact that you really have to
stay close to it to not overshoot the
maximum height that you're allowed to
build I think it works out pretty well
and I try to also make it look good from
two main perspectives so I'm trying to
make this look decent from this sort of
perspective coming from the lake but at
the same time if you're looking down
from the hills if you're looking from
the perspective of the park entrance I
think it works decently as well I don't
know for me sometimes or actually no I'm
always looking for a balance between how
a coaster looks and how it would
realistically ride and for this one I
think it does OK on both fronts although
it isn't quite as realistic in terms of
layouts regarding it well compared to
how it looks but at the same time
spinning coasters aren't usually
terrain conforming coasters so it's it's
definitely a bit of an odd one if you
compare it to real-life spinning
coasters which tend to be much more
compact and do a certain the sets amount
of elements and this one doesn't really
do that now for the station
I'm keeping it very simple here the
station's interesting because I split it
into a loading and unloading section as
spinning coasters will often do in real
life or at least I think they should
because not doing that kind of makes the
whole thing a little bit less efficient
and in game it always works out as well
because it means that people don't have
to spend as much time in the station
loading although for this coaster it
doesn't really matter because it does
run on block brakes and people have to
wait for the next car to clearly lift
hill and guests don't take that long to
get into the cars so usually it's fine
in the game anyway but yeah I guess for
realism purposes and just because unlike
its I wanted to have an unloading and
loading station as well and then over
the loading station we have the taller
section of the building and the
unloading station with the exits is a
smaller part jutting out from that and
at the back we have a small cover going
over the cue line so that people aren't
you know exposed to the elements while
waiting in line now there are a couple
of quirks to this coaster that I'll have
to discuss as we move to the real time
section in a bit but for one I had to
change the the lift Hill speed to make
sure that they don't get stuck on some
of the block brakes because I want this
thing to continue running and I don't
want people to suddenly be stopped at
one of the block brakes to let the next
block be cleared but the bigger problem
was that the final block was way too
long so I ended up having to replace the
final block break with a irregular break
because it didn't actually make it from
the final block break onward the car
couldn't even reach the station so I had
to remove that and have one last train
on the circuit which is a bit of a shame
but oh well it doesn't really matter too
much because it doesn't actually cost me
that much money in the long run if that
was a bit too difficult to understand
let's go to a quick real time section
and
see how the bike is doing all right so
that was a bit of a rollercoaster you
guys didn't see it but I tried to make
this Park work right after the
time-lapse and really tried my best to
manage prices and employees and all that
stuff and it just didn't work I just
kept while making losses time after time
until I was bankrupt so that was
terrible but I realized that one
shortcoming was probably the sole cause
of this and that was then I didn't have
a high intensity ride and people were
very upset about this and started
demolishing everything and not really
wanting to pay for anything
so on my retry I decided to build this
enterprise put a tiny little no effort
skew next to it and that's pretty much
all I did differently and it made all
the difference because now I'm making
profits
decent as it is it's not always great as
you can see but generally I'm making a
pretty decent profits I've been doing
research and fixing the park up and I've
even been able to get very close to the
goals of this scenario it's slightly
less good at the moment but I actually
made it for a few times and I think it's
not as good at the moment for perhaps
vandalism reasons which keeps being a
challenge but the goals are inside and
I've almost made it I just need to make
sure that I can hold them for two months
so yeah interestingly it didn't go that
well for a long time but as soon as it
started going well it just kind of went
well really quickly and I've barely
played the scenario for a few months and
I'm already doing this well in year two
so really happy about that and I guess
my next plan of attack is just to build
something over here to fill up this
empty space in what is going to be there
sort of Main Street area of the park and
also put some scenery around the
enterprise finish up some of the paths
on this side and on this side which
don't really have the the textures and
detail of the rest of the park yet and
hire a bunch more mechanics and security
people because people are still
destroying everything and vandalism is
still a big issue but that aside I'm
making money
the rides are running well and people
are happy about
so let's just keep going and see where
it ends up all right now if my voice
sounds a little bit shabby for those
parts that's because I got a call again
don't know what it is this like the
fifth time in two months that I got sick
somehow so maybe I've complained about
this before but I need to get my stuff
together anyway that's that's part of
the reason why it took me so long to get
this video out but by now I want to get
this out as quickly as possible so I'm
just recording this right now while I
feel that I have the possibility to
anyway that is wildly off topic again
for this part I'm gonna try and finish
the sort of main streets main plaza area
and I figured it would work well to add
another building with large overhanging
roofs because it really you know makes
the tone of the alpine village quite a
bit more believable
I just have to make sure that every time
I do this I have an appropriate space
where I can make one of these buildings
that is completely off grid and this
square over here feels like just the
right place so again this building is
very much inspired by buildings that
you'd find in Xero or Switzerland or
North Italy these kinds of areas very
large big overhanging roofs kind of
almost like a farm building really the
kind of building that you'd find only in
really small towns because big cities to
have more standard sort of baroque city
blocks but these old traditional Alpine
houses I think are really cool and
they're actually quite large as well if
you look at in general the size of
buildings on this well
scenario I guess they're actually pretty
large compared to what I usually do just
because I want to fit them in on four by
four spaces typically and you know use
some smaller buildings to fit in the
spaces between that so speaking of that
I did want to connect a building to the
church which is a bit strange
I suppose normally you wouldn't really
see that too much but for finishing off
the streets and blocking the view of
this sort of shabby looking area behind
the church I decided to add this small
house here anyway I don't think I'm
gonna give it a purpose it's really just
here for decorative reasons and to
finish the main plaza in a nice way
but then again usually I do build
buildings beforehand and then try to
come up with a possible use for them
later on and at this point I already
have the bathroom buildings I already
have some food and drink stalls and I've
got a bunch of flat rides in some of
these buildings so I don't really need
anything else it's really just scenery
at this point and with a little bit of
foliage especially planters I think you
do get a decent feel for the Alpine
style I really love the fact that they
always have a lot of window boxes with
flowers in the midst really easy to make
buildings look nice with some foliage so
I always appreciate if you can see
matically add a bunch of foliage to it
and know this is something I always
bring up but just the fact that
architects when they're making renders
always put down way too many trees and
shrubs around their buildings and
especially on the balconies just says a
lot about how much foliage sort of helps
in creating a very charming and
attractive urban setting so that's
definitely something that I always want
to focus on quite a bit as well and I
really wasn't sure what to do with the
enterprise section over here because I
never really intended for this
enterprise to be here it's really just
for gameplay reasons that I need this
thing to even make a profit in the park
so I'm just gonna generically theme the
area around here with a bunch of trees
and some path details and a small cover
for the cue but that's just about it I
just know that it always asks me to see
this empty area in the ring underneath
the enterprise and I know I really don't
have to do anything with it but I
decided to add some support structures
to it and a little bit of decoration as
though it were some kind of fairground
ride that needs to be set up like that
even though realistically I know in this
game it doesn't really need to but yeah
the enterprise on its own just feels a
bit empty and I'm not a big fan of that
large empty circle in the middle of it
that you get typically so I did change
the queue a little bit made it go zigzag
a bit because that first queue is purely
just to get people in there so this is
also in nicer shape to add a small roof
too and make sure that people are
shelled
from whatever elements are gonna attack
them in this scenario I don't think the
weather is actually too bad but it
always helps to add something like this
to be honest I think there are flat
rides which are easier to theme and flat
rides which are definitely a lot harder
to theme and the enterprise is just one
of those things where I never really
know exactly what to do with it because
it moves around a lot you can't really
put anything above it or around it so
you're very limited in terms of what you
can actually do with it so my timing for
these things tend to be very generic and
very basic but yeah I guess that's
something that can't really be helped
now this part is a bit more interesting
I decided to add a train station to the
train stations like a proper train
station building to the train stations
of the train that's already in the
scenario I didn't really know exactly
what to do I didn't have a specific plan
for this I just started doodling a
building and just hoping it would turn
into something decent but it's a very
generic sort of train station type
building with one main section parallel
to the rails and some additions here and
there and of course in the end of small
spire because that's something that I
can never really help but adding
although something that I kind of wish I
did a little bit more is that I did do a
roof where it gets a bit steeper in the
middle which is a nice way to deviate
from a standard flats simple roof and I
think especially in this case it adds
some much-needed heights to the profile
of the building and just overall with
that one sort of gable facade sticking
out on the front it does make it look a
bit more inviting from the sort of path
perspective and I did decide to keep the
foliage in front of this very open so
that's well theoretically if you're
looking from the path you can see this
station in the distance a little bit up
the hill with some very close to the
ground low shrubbery kind of foliage in
front of it so I'm imagining that this
would be a pretty cool scene to see from
a pile
perspective
and for the spire I'm doing something
very simple I guess don't an experiment
too much with that but I did eventually
change the color because looking at this
I do realize that it's a lot of brown
and even though that's sort of the thing
that comes with the territory of making
Alpine theme park I definitely want to
have a bit more color in there as well
oh and to finish the village a little
bit I decided to add another slightly
off-grid building over here except this
one is a bit smaller only two floors
with one whole floor and then an upper
floor just kind of underneath this very
shallow roof and it doesn't really serve
any purpose it's just there to finish
off the village a little bit it's always
tough to transition from an area with
very dense architecture and just a dense
urban fabric in general to a more
outdoor forested areas so this is kind
of gonna be one of those transition
buildings that doesn't really serve a
purpose and it's kind of a little bit
smaller than the actual useful buildings
just to kind of blend everything
together a little bit better I do have
to say as far as architecture goes this
is actually probably some of my
favourites
Main Street sections in Scenario so far
it just works out better in the team and
I expected and of course it is a redo so
everything that I did wrong on my first
try I tried to take into account here
but I think in the end it actually
worked out pretty well especially with
the church with the square in front of
it like that I'm pretty happy with the
result only thing not to pay too much
attention to I guess is the fact that
the fountain is not perfectly straight
in front of the church because that
fountain section is three by three
whereas the church is four tiles wide so
everything is a little bit asymmetrical
but personally that's just something I
like doing but I guess that really comes
down to personal preference as well I
know a lot of people like to make
everything symmetrical but for me it's
already big deal that the church itself
is symmetrical I was really considering
at some points making two different
spires on both sides but then I just
thought that's something that these
Pyne baroque churches don't really tend
to do so I'll at least give them that
and over here I'm just trying to add a
bit of scenery to the parts of the park
which I'm not really adding anything to
but then at least I want to change a bit
so that they fit a bit better with the
parts that I've been doing and I think
people who pay a lot of attention to my
path work have probably already noticed
that I'm straying away from what I did
in most of the episode so far I used to
really have these threads of path that
kind of intersect so you get different
colors that sort of lined through each
other whereas the approach that I'm
taking for this one is to just get three
different shades of each path type and
plop them down kind of randomly
everywhere to get a bit more texture
overall but so you don't really get
these different threads of different
colors that runs through each other and
I'm not sure which approach I like more
I do think this one's a bit more
realistic but it might not be as
interesting to look at and it's also
much more subtle it's something that you
don't notice quite as quickly I think
anyway moving on to one of the last
parts of this video and this is the
other train station for this one I once
again just decided to do a little bit
and see where it ends up I do think I
like this one a bit more because it's
more out there and more unique and a bit
more daring I was less afraid to make
mistakes and just kind of did whatever I
feel like and even though the general
setup is the same with a spire on one
side a long parallel to the rails kind
of roof and then one facade pointing
toward the entrance to kind of make this
building looks a bit more inviting it is
a lot it is very much different actually
in terms of colors and pieces and just a
bit more experimental one of the things
that I actually really you know like
more and more the more that I play the
game is do those basic shapes and the
fact that you can just
resize them to whatever you want so it's
really great for making smaller spires
or as is the case with this building
creating a top floor of the spire tower
which is slightly more narrow than
everything underneath it so that creates
a very neat spire and just altogether
the green roof of the of the tower
plus the red roof of the middle section
in the brown roof of the entrance just
makes for a nice color combination that
I think always works out anyway that's
it for this episode so let's get back to
the game and see how the park is doing
all right we're almost there looks like
I'm gonna make it this time and this is
always a bit awkward anyway isn't it
there we go and that is the scenario so
that actually wasn't as difficult the
second time around as I expected it to
be but the first time was a major
struggle I guess it kind of shows that
sometimes you have this butterfly effect
of just doing one or two things wrong
and it just ends up crashing your entire
scenario so if there's any kind of
gameplay tip that I could give based on
my experience it's to always keep
multiple saves of your progress at least
that's the thing that saved me in this
case so I didn't have to restart the
whole thing but at least I could start
from a better perspective and get it
done this time around alright now you're
probably dying to let me do a bit of a
trip of the park so I actually want to
start off with the woody because that's
something that I still haven't shown off
but something that's really interesting
is that this thing has been making
better and better better profit as the
years go on just because it wasn't
really functioning up to full capacity
in the beginning because I didn't have
enough people in the park but there was
this kind of cumulative effect getting
more people into the park and thus this
ride making more money and thus the
whole scenario becoming a bit more easy
as time went on as well especially if
you're struggling I think just putting
your money into loans and building a
bunch of rides can really help in this
aspects because it makes sure
all of your rights are functioning at
their utmost capabilities I suppose so
yeah as always I need to keep everything
very close to the ground and when the
scenario is being made at least I have
the advantage that I could do some
terraforming so you do see some basic
terraforming around the layout of this
coaster especially in here we have this
valley that you go through so that's
something that you can't do when you're
playing a scenario but it kind of does
show off how you can use the terrain to
your advantage and keep your coasters
low to the ground while at the same time
giving them an interesting layouts so
yeah this was definitely a write that I
thought would be interesting to fit into
this scenario it's also very much
inspired by the coaster in rainbow
valley in roller coaster tycoon 2 and I
think people who played that game
probably recognize the layout in that a
little bit very closer to ground lots of
curves a little bit cgc I also and
there's a touch of balderdash in it for
me especially with the way that it
interacts with the lake over here I
thought balderdash is just this really
really cool wooden coaster and probably
one of the best ones out there would
really love to ride it one day but yeah
that was also a big inspiration on this
one now let's cut to the spinning
coaster which is actually the only
coaster I built in this entire episode
kind of rare to only build one layouts
but I think it's penny coaster is the
best thing that I could go for here
given that the Alpine Coaster is very
hard to make profitable and the bobsled
coaster is also not too easy to work
with this is a decent low budget yet
terrain conforming spinning coaster and
I think it does more or less what
spinning coasters - well the only
problem is that the last section of the
layout doesn't have the block brakes
anymore because well it has to go
through this break section here with a
decent speed in order to even finish the
final half of the layouts so that's a
bit unfortunate it's definitely not the
most efficient spinning coaster out
there but I do like the way that the
layout interacts with the paths and the
way that it just works with the scenery
in general so that is the spinning
coaster I actually think it might look a
bit better from this perspective it
really clearly shows off all of the
curves and the way
it hoax deterring as it goes down the
hill but but yeah this is honestly one
of the first scenarios where I really
tried to make everything look decent
from all of the four basic isometric
perspectives too often I just focus on
one perspective but given that the
scenario is surrounded by hills on all
sides I wanted to try and put some more
effort into making it look good from
different angles as well so that's
definitely something that kind of worked
well on the end I think and yeah then we
have here just the Main Street area with
the church which just completely
dominates the park and which i think is
quite a weenie it's a bit strange I
suppose to have a religious building
like that as a main weenie that's not
something you really see in theme parks
which I suppose tend to be a bit more
just commercial but given the theme of
this park I really really just wanted to
do it like this it's Betty a girl
hornish I suppose as well and yeah that
is basically it for this scenario so I
guess I'm gonna call it a day here I'll
just save and head over to the main menu
I can't over it's an autosave of course
so this was actually my third attempt
attempt one was just the original file
that I didn't really do anything wrong
on but attempt to was the one where I
messed up everything so I think saves in
that sense kind of helped me out here
but I'm actually really curious which
Park or which scenario I'm gonna get out
of this because I don't really remember
so let me just see for a second ah
we finished hickory hill and we got the
spire of the main building as a
decoration I actually didn't know that
but that's pretty cool and from there
I'm not sure if we're gonna get a new
one no okay so that's it I'm gonna have
to either play kaiserburg or Sakura
Gardens at this point and I'll have to
be honest I've been working on
kaiserburg for a while but I've been
working on it on my laptop and I'm not
sure when I'm gonna be able to finish
that one but I'll see but it's something
that I've been working on at the same
time as I agree he'll so hopefully I'll
be able to get that out it's a bit more
quickly than Hickory Hill which took a
few months
strangely enough so yeah I'm gonna try
to be a bit better but I can't make any
promises because I'm kind of busy with
some other stuff as well anyway I hope
to see you guys in the next episode
which I can already tell is gonna be
really interesting and actually a little
bit similar to this episode and I'd like
to thank you for watching this video and
see you next time